Prof: Okay.
Well, we've seen now how the
early Tudors managed to
reestablish the authority of the
monarchy;
how that achievement was
threatened by the succession
crisis which was looming under
Henry VIII;
how that problem was met by
actions which further extended
royal authority over the church,
but at the same time,
of course, introduced a new
form of instability into the
kingdom--
potential conflict over
religion.
But that wasn't all that was
going on and there were other
sources of instability which
were set in motion at around the
same time in the second quarter
of the sixteenth century.
What adds additional complexity
to the whole situation is the
fact that there were
simultaneous shifts in some of
the basic aspects of economic
and social life which in 1500
would have been more or less
taken for granted.
The problem then had been
political instability,
not social instability.
But soon social instability was
to be on the agenda.
And people knew by the 1530s
and 1540s that they lived in
radically changing times in more
ways than one.
The phenomenon of which they
were most acutely aware was
rising prices,
rising prices for the basic
necessities of life.
Prices of goods had been fairly
stable for most of the fifteenth
and early sixteenth centuries,
but around about the second
decade of the sixteenth century
they began rising.
If you look at your handout,
section one,
you'll find there an index of
prices for what's described as a
basket of basic consumables,
mostly foodstuffs and other
essentials of life.
You can see from that index,
which stands at around 100 in
1500, how prices rose rapidly in
the course of the sixteenth
century.
At first it was a modest trend.
It picked up momentum in the
1530s.
Price rises were very rapid
indeed in the 1540s and '50s and
they continued to rise more
slowly thereafter.
So, they faced a problem of
inflation, and the causes of
that inflation were complex.
They're much debated,
but amongst them one of the
most principal seems to have
been the fact that population
was also growing.
The pressure was being felt of
increasing numbers of people on
relatively inelastic resources,
forcing up prices.
If you look at section two of
your handout,
you'll see the best figures
available from demographic
historians of what the
population of England was at
different points in the earlier
sixteenth century.
The best estimates we have
suggest that in the 1520s about
2.4 million.
By the 1550s that had risen to
about 3 million,
by 1570 3.3 million,
and still rising.
The annual rate of increase can
be calculated and it's there on
the right-hand side.
In the 1540s about 0.64% per
annum, in the 1560s almost 1%
per annum, 1570s over 1% per
annum.
These are quite rapid rates of
increase for a preindustrial
population.
In fact, that kind of rate of
population increase was not
matched again in England until
the late eighteenth century at
the height of the Industrial
Revolution.
So the population was rising.
Now explaining why that was so
is far from easy,
but in all likelihood it was to
do with a fall in death rates in
the early sixteenth century in a
population which had a fairly
high fertility rate and high
propensity to grow if it wasn't
culled by severe mortality.
So death rates,
still high by our standards,
seem to have been falling
somewhat.
If you're interested in that
kind of historical demography
and would like to pursue the
issue of population dynamics,
then I'd be happy to advise you
on more detailed reading.
But for the moment it's enough
to just register the essential
facts: prices are rising;
population is rising;
the two are probably connected.
What I want to focus on today
is the fallout from all of that:
some of the stresses in society
which were produced by this
dynamic of population growth and
price inflation,
how it impacted on different
groups in society.
And one can start at the top
with the landlords,
gentlemen, noblemen,
the monarchy.
In most cases the bulk of
landlords' incomes,
as you know,
came from rents and they needed
that income to sustain the
lifestyles which were
appropriate to their station as
gentlemen,
to sustain their magnificence.
In that situation their biggest
problem as the sixteenth century
went on was rising prices but an
inflexible income.
At worst many of them had
tenants who enjoyed fixed rents;
they'd been granted fixed rents
at some point in the past.
At best they were in a position
to periodically modify the rents
they got for their lands,
but they were still relatively
inflexible.
Land was often granted for long
periods of time on a fixed
agreement for that term.
It might be twenty,
thirty years.
Land was also let according to
customs,
as you know,
which had been established in
particular areas which might
inhibit the landlords' capacity
to adjust the rent levels.
That's very bad news when
prices are rising.
So, how did these people cope?
For the most part landlords
coped by gradually trying to
alter the terms on which they
granted their land to the
peasantry.
They tried to let it for
shorter leases which they could
renegotiate more often,
try to get the lease down to
seven years,
ten years or whatever rather
than ninety,
which had been quite common in
the past.
They also tried to change local
customs regarding what kind of
fine or down payment they could
get when they let land.
For example,
on the estates of the Herbert
family,
which were located in Wiltshire
in the southwest,
in the first half of the
sixteenth century they managed
to roughly double the fines
which they were getting when a
new tenant took land from them.
Well, it was only possible for
landlords to squeeze their
tenants a little harder in that
way because land was in demand.
The rise in population,
rise in population for the
first time in a century and a
half,
meant that there was demand for
land in a way that hadn't really
been known since the fourteenth
century.
There's a lot of evidence of
people nibbling at wasteland,
forest land,
moor land, bringing land into
cultivation.
In the Forest of Inglewood for
example,
which was located up in the
northwest of England,
up here, there was a survey
made of illegal 'encroachments'
in the forest,
people cutting out a little
piece of land for themselves
where they could squat,
and it revealed that over a
period of twenty or thirty years
almost 200 encroachments had
been made into the forest there.
So pressure on the land.
And inevitably also as the
population rose the size of the
wholly landless population rose
too.
There were more young people
surviving to adulthood for whom
there was no inheritance,
no place on the land.
Now those shifting
circumstances,
the pressures on landlords,
the pressures that they'd pass
on to their tenants,
the pressure of population
growth, helped to explain the
emergence in the early sixteenth
century of some quite severe
tensions in the relationships
between landlords and farm
tenants.
Tensions in particular over
customs and the emergence of one
particular cardinal grievance,
the grievance of 'enclosure'.
Now as I've explained earlier,
in some areas of the kingdom
agriculture had never been
practiced in great open fields
but had been practiced already
on enclosed farms.
Before 1500,
in the areas where there
was--there were--open fields,
some of them had been
reorganized by enclosing them to
make sheep pastures.
This was done by landlords who
were short of tenants.
They found that doing that was
a good way of keeping their land
in production,
although a low-intensity
production,
when otherwise it might go
vacant or might be unprofitable.
Wool was in demand from the
cloth industry so they went over
to a kind of sheep ranching.
At the time that wasn't
particularly controversial,
but after the 1510s steps to
enclose land which had formerly
been open became much more
controversial.
In the Midlands,
which was a major
wool-supplying area,
many landlords withdrew land
from the plow to turn it into
sheep ranches despite the
growing demand from tenants for
land.
Some landlords also took in and
enclosed for their own use land
which had formerly been the
common pastureland of particular
villages.
Thereby they reduced the area
of common pasture available to
their tenants,
which was a further grievance,
especially since common land
was particularly valuable in
conditions of land hunger.
Well, these changing conditions
meant that enclosure,
which had previously been
merely a tactic you could adopt
on your estate,
became a quite significant
grievance in many areas of the
kingdom.
It seemed to many people a very
visible sign of the changing
balance of power in rural
society between lords and
tenants.
Sir Thomas More in his
Utopia refers to the
phenomenon of sheep eating men
in England at this time,
reflecting that sense of
grievance.
It's for these reasons that
issues of rents and fines and
customs and common land became a
quite explosive cocktail in
landlord-tenant relations by the
mid-sixteenth century.
And there was also a little
more to it than that.
The economic trends and the
population trends of the period
were gradually producing a
greater differentiation in
village society amongst tenants.
There were those who did quite
well in these circumstances,
especially the bigger farmers,
the yeomanry.
Quite often they held part of
their land in freehold;
they were somewhat protected.
Quite often they produced a
large surplus which they could
market and if prices were rising
they could make bigger profits.
They were able to pay higher
rents without too much trouble.
They might take on more land to
extend their operations,
and if they wanted to do that
they were in a far better
position to compete for
available land than were their
poorer neighbors.
So this is a period when one
sees the yeomanry becoming
increasingly differentiated in
their wealth and living
standards from their poorer
neighbors.
These were people who were able
to benefit from the trends of
the period.
They showed a lot of ambition
in the way they did that,
and the ambition of those who
were best able to take advantage
of the trends of the--
this generation,
that ambition is also shown in
response to another economic
development of the period and
this time it's an economic
development which wasn't
directly connected to population
or price trends but was
connected to religious changes.
And I'm thinking of course of
the Dissolution of the
Monasteries and the bringing on
to the market of vast quantities
of former monastic land.
Some figures relating to this
are there on your handout in
section three.
Basically, between 1536 and
1540 about 60% of the land which
was owned by the church was
transferred to the crown through
the Dissolution of the
Monasteries.
Many studies have been done of
individual counties.
In the county of Essex,
down here to the east of
London, for example,
the church had owned about 28%
of the manors in that county.
By 1540, after the Dissolution
it owned only 2%;
a massive transfer of land.
Well, these seizures of church
land were probably intended by
Thomas Cromwell to endow the
crown in perpetuity with massive
land holdings which would render
it absolutely unchallengeable
and indeed might even render it
independent of any grants of
taxation from Parliament.
But if that was Cromwell's
intention it failed to
materialize, because most of the
monastic land was quite rapidly
disposed of by the crown.
By the time Henry VIII himself
died in 1547,
he had already sold something
like two thirds of the monastery
land which had come in to him,
and still more of this land was
sold later.
For example,
there's been a study done of
the whole of Wales which shows
that of the monastic land there
60% had gone by the death of
Henry in 1547 and by the time
Elizabeth came to the throne in
1558 75% of the monastery land
had been disposed of.
Why would the crown dispose of
the land in this kind of way?
Well, basically to pay for wars;
wars which were getting more
expensive, requiring fortresses,
modern weapons,
new ships and so forth.
Henry VIII in his last years
engaged in short,
inconclusive,
utterly futile,
assertions of his rights,
as he saw them,
against France and against
Scotland resulting in wars and
massive expenditure which
accounted for much of the
monastic land.
For our purposes today it's
interesting to note the results
of studies which have looked at
the identities of who's buying
this land from the crown.
Quite a lot went to the heads
of established noble and gentry
families,
people who were anxious to take
advantage of this wonderful
opportunity to consolidate their
estates,
to rationalize the estates and
so forth,
to build up their holdings in
particular areas of their
strength.
Another group who emerged quite
strongly are people who were the
youngest sons of such gentry and
noble families,
people who in the normal course
of events would expect most of
the family's property to pass to
their older brothers,
but who now had an opportunity
to get in and get some land for
themselves.
Younger brothers.
They could set up cadet
branches of the family and
sometimes they did so with the
money which they had generated
in trade or in professions.
Younger sons were often put
into trade or into professions
and were able to make the money
which enabled them to return to
landed society and set
themselves up as minor
gentlemen.
Another significant group were
upwardly mobile people from the
middle ranks of society:
yeoman farmers piecing together
field to field until they could
emerge with a sufficient estate
to call themselves gentlemen;
people from the towns who had
no gentry ancestry,
perhaps lawyers,
perhaps merchants,
prosperous craftsmen and
tradesmen,
who were able to acquire land
and its superior social status,
perhaps in some cases on a
level which would again bring
them into the lower ranks of the
gentry.
So there were customers enough
for this monastic land,
and to serve their needs there
were many speculators.
A lot of the monastic land was
bought by speculators who
rapidly sold it on.
The overall effects of this was
a kind of feeding frenzy in the
land market.
It resulted of course not only
in the severe reduction of the
position of the church as a
great landowner,
but it also resulted ultimately
in a very significant rise in
both the numbers of those who
called themselves gentlemen and
in the relative wealth of the
gentry as a whole.
So some people were doing very
well out of all of this,
but of course it's not all
buoyancy.
No process of change of this
kind ever is,
and so one has to ask,
"who were the losers in
these processes?"
And there are some large and
quite obvious groups.
Amongst the losers were the
small farm tenants who couldn't
easily meet rising rents,
who didn't sell enough on the
market to produce the profits
which would pay them,
who were finding it difficult
to make ends meet.
Then there were those who
were--one could think of as
would-be farm tenants,
those who might aspire to
getting a foothold on the land
but found it increasingly
difficult because rents were
rising,
fines were rising and so forth,
and they couldn't compete with
the bigger guys in the village
who could take up land that came
available on the local market.
It could be quite a difficult
time for the young in that
respect.
But above all there were the
growing numbers of landless
people in the countryside or in
the towns whose living depended
principally on what they could
earn from wage earning as
laborers and the rights to use
commons which they might enjoy
in the places where they lived.
Those who depended on wages
were particularly hard hit by
inflation and despite the fact
that prices were rising,
squeezing their living
standards, wages rose only
slowly because the population
was growing and there was plenty
of labor available.
Wages tended to remain pretty
sticky at customary levels for
long periods of time.
That meant that people's real
wages, the real purchasing power
of their wages,
was falling.
And quite close studies of this
have been done and they suggest
that between 1510 and 1550 the
purchasing power of wages fell
by about 40% in the south of
England.
By the 1550s,
they were down 50% and they
began to recover modestly only
in the later sixteenth century.
So these were quite hard times
for a lot of people.
William Harrison,
who wrote a famous description
of England at the beginning of
the reign of Elizabeth,
described how many of what he
described as the "inferior
sort of people"
lived principally on what he
called "white meats":
eggs and cheese and bread.
In times of dearth they were
particularly hard hit and might
have to live on peas and beans
or even ground acorns which they
tried to bake into bread.
He added, "I will not say
that this extremity is often
also found in times of plenty,
but if I should I could easily
stand my trial."
That's Harrison's ironic
comment on the living standards
of the poor in his time.
Well, all of this is reflected
in a growing contemporary
concern with the problem of
poverty.
There had always been poor of
course, but poverty as a major
social problem hadn't been a
major issue in the fifteenth
century.
It was more a matter of the
poverty that resulted from life
cycle crises of a small minority
of people: the widowed,
the aged, the sick,
orphaned children.
These were the ones that
contemporaries referred to as
the "impotent poor,"
those who could not help
themselves,
those who were poor by
circumstance beyond their
control.
But as the sixteenth century
advanced people began talking
and writing about poverty in two
worryingly expanded forms.
They first became aware of the
problem of vagrancy,
the problem of what they called
'rogues and vagabonds',
homeless people visible on the
streets of the towns or on the
roads of the countryside.
People like one man who was
arrested by the justices of the
peace over near the Welsh border
who,
in the examination which they
took from him,
told them that he was a person
who dwells no--
I'm quoting the
examination--who "dwells
nowhere nor has no abiding but
where he might find work."
The vagrant looking for work,
moving around the countryside.
People like this were a much
more common sight as the
sixteenth century advanced.
It's quite interesting that in
his translation of the New
Testament William Tyndale,
in trying to describe a scene
from the Acts of the Apostles
where Saint Paul is attacked by
a mob in Thessalonica,
translated the Greek word which
literally means people standing
in the street,
he translated it as
"vagabonds."
When Tyndale tried to imagine
people hanging around in the
street he imagined them as some
of these vagrants who he would
have seen in the streets of
London.
So vagrancy,
rogues and vagabonds,
are emerging as a significant
problem.
On the other hand,
there was the growing problem
of what they described as the
"laboring poor,"
people whose whole style of
life was based increasingly on a
kind of economy of makeshifts,
getting work wherever they
could.
Working, certainly,
but finding it increasingly
difficult to make ends meet.
The laboring poor,
people who would also fall into
really severe poverty if they
suffered any misfortune;
if they couldn't find work,
if there was a depression in
the cloth industry,
if they fell sick,
and so forth.
These people were especially
visible in areas where wage
workers were concentrated,
principally the towns or those
areas of the countryside where
many people worked in rural
industries.
Okay then.
Let's just take stock.
By the 1540s,
rising prices and demographic
growth had seen in some ways a
quickening of economic activity.
For some people this brought
new opportunities and indeed
enhanced prosperity.
But at the same time there was
also a growing sense of tension
in the relationships between
landlords and their peasant
tenants,
an emerging problem of land
hunger,
a growing problem of a wage
laboring population which was
very vulnerable to poverty on an
unaccustomed scale.
Now people were aware of these
changes,
they were aware of the
tensions, but from their
perspective at the time it was
the symptoms of change which
were more apparent than the
actual causes.
It was exceedingly difficult
for people in the sixteenth
century to comprehend what was
happening to them.
They didn't keep official
statistics.
The figures which are on your
handout have been calculated by
historians using a variety of
sources.
Contemporaries didn't have
information of this kind.
They tended to perceive changes
and emergent problems of this
kind through their inherited
attitudes, their essentially
medieval moral philosophy;
a view of the world in which
economic behavior wasn't treated
as a distinct area of activity,
a phenomenon to be studied in
itself by the science of
economics,
they saw it as a branch of
personal and social morality.
The ideal world in their view
was the world of the
commonwealth,
which I've described to you.
They saw these problems as
failings in the ideal of the
commonwealth,
failings which could be
attributed to the misdeeds of
specific people.
Well, these ideas not only
persisted throughout the early
sixteenth century but they were
powerfully reemphasized in the
1540s with the emergence of a
group of moralists,
most of them Protestant
clergymen, in the reign of
Edward VI,
who addressed these social and
economic grievances.
They were known at the time as
the "Commonwealth's
Men" because they talked
constantly about the needs of
the commonwealth.
Such people also saw the
reformation not simply in terms
of the jurisdictional
independence of the Church of
England from the Church of Rome,
or simply in terms of
fundamental doctrinal changes.
They also thought it was an
opportunity for the
re-moralizing of society,
the revitalization of Christian
values in society.
They advocated an ideal
Christian commonwealth.
They thought this was the
opportunity to achieve it,
and yet they saw all around
them evidence of the corruption
of social relationships by what
they saw as the cardinal sin of
covetousness,
one of their favorite words,
covetousness--
greed--and the pernicious idea
again which they constantly
refer to that,
quote, "every man may do
with his own as he will."
The motion that every man may
do with his own as he will,
which they regarded as an
unchristian attitude.
In their view,
worldly goods were given by God
to be handled with stewardship,
with an interest to society as
a whole.
So their social vision was
essentially conservative.
They saw change in terms of
social dislocation and moral
corruption.
They denounced the
representatives of covetousness
whom they identified.
They spoke for example of
"ungentle gentlemen."
They attacked what they called
the "caterpillars of the
commonwealth"
who were eating up its green
shoots.
They attacked what they saw as
exploitation and oppression of
the poor, and they did all of
this in a language reminiscent
of Old Testament prophets.
R.H. Tawney,
a great historian of these
changes,
says they used the moral
rhetoric, in his words,
of "an age that had
rediscovered the Bible."
Well, it hadn't rediscovered it.
It had discovered it for the
first time in English,
and as I say,
the language of Jeremiah or
Isaiah is the kind of language
that they used to denounce what
they saw as a world out of
joint.
Well, the pamphlets written by
these people in the 1540s and
1550s are a quite magnificent
literature of moral indignation.
It still has the capacity to
thrill when you read it.
It indicated also what's been
described by one recent
historian as a "crisis of
legitimation,"
a crisis of legitimation.
The world seemed out of joint
in so many ways,
but response to change also
took a more direct form.
There were not only those who
were appealing for reform,
for moral reformation,
for people to behave as they
should,
there were also those who were
prepared to directly resist
these changes especially in the
countryside.
From about the 1530s onwards,
researchers working on records
of local government and on the
courts find that the country was
increasingly pockmarked with
minor forms of disorder as the
peasantry of particular
localities resisted initiatives
on the part of their landlords,
perhaps rioting against the
enclosing of fields or of common
land and so forth,
or against changes in their
customs and tenures.
And such resistance becomes
above all evident in some of the
great risings of the commons
which took place in the middle
third of the sixteenth century,
risings which convulsed first
the north of England and then
the east of England in
particular.
The first of these risings was
the Pilgrimage of Grace of 1536,
a rising of much of the north
of England.
This was a complex event.
It combined religious hostility
to the reformation and a desire
to defend the monasteries,
which had been ordered to be
dissolved,
with a variety of other
grievances and in particular
agrarian grievances against the
enclosing of commons and the
forcing up of entry fines to
land.
It was described by those who
took part in it as a
"pilgrimage of grace for
the commonwealth,"
for the commonwealth as a
whole,
and those who mustered for the
pilgrimage,
some 20,000 men,
regarded themselves as
defending each branch of the
commonwealth.
They wanted the king to turn
away from his evil counselors,
they wanted the ancient rights
of the nobility to be properly
recognized,
they wanted the rights of the
church to be respected and,
as they put in one of their
statements of grievances,
they also demanded that the
"commonalty be used as they
should be"--
"the commonality be used
as they should be"--
particularly in matters
relating to the land.
So this was a complex event.
It led to the rebel army
eventually mustering near
Pontefract in South Yorkshire,
having taken the city of York
where it faced a standoff with
royal troops under the Duke of
Norfolk.
The Duke negotiated with the
rebels,
persuaded those gentlemen who
had joined them,
in particular,
to act as negotiators with the
crown,
promised that their grievances
would be met,
and persuaded them to disperse.
The rebels were wrong to trust
Norfolk.
He was already writing to the
crown that he regarded no
promises made to a rebel as
binding.
And when the crown got the
opportunity with the flurry of a
few more agrarian troubles in
the northwest at the beginning
of the following year royal
troops went in and suppressed
them with considerable violence.
Robert Aske,
the leader of the rebels who
was a lawyer from York,
along with a number of other
figures, was arrested,
tried and executed for treason.
That was the Pilgrimage of
Grace, probably the biggest
threat that the Tudor monarchy
ever faced.
Then in 1549 came another
widespread burst of unrest known
as the "Camping Time,"
because many tenants from
particular areas were gathering
together in protest and forming
camps.
These were scattered all over
central, eastern and southern
England.
Many of these camps were
ultimately dispersed.
The Earl of Arundel in Sussex
for example,
down towards the south coast,
met the protesting peasants,
assured them that he would
speak for them on their behalf,
and persuaded them to disperse.
This was the way that it could
sometimes be handled and Arundel
kept his word;
he did speak for them.
But one particular rising did
not disperse and that was the
one in the county of Norfolk led
by Robert Kett,
a yeoman farmer.
Kett's rebels advanced to set
up a camp just outside Norwich,
on Mousehold Heath outside
Norwich,
where Kett, who was very well
organized,
had a supply system to keep
the--to keep his army,
as it was by then,
well supplied.
He sat under an oak tree on the
heath which was known as the Oak
of Reformation and there with
his counsel he delivered justice
to the local farm tenants
against their gentlemen
landlords.
The principal grievances of the
Norfolk rising were agrarian.
They were protesting against
enhanced rents and against the
abuses of common land by their
landlords.
And they're also remarkable in
that Kett's rebels refused to
disperse.
Eventually, a royal army was
sent against them.
It consisted mostly of
mercenaries who had been hired
from Germany and Italy.
They didn't dare use English
troops for fear they would
sympathize with the rebels.
Kett's army refused to disperse
and went down fighting in a
battle at Dussindale just
outside the city of Norwich.
It's been said of these peasant
rebels that they were trying to
create "a world in which
gentlemen were kept at arm's
length."
They were trying to preserve
the rights that they had in the
land in a changing economic
climate which threatened to
diminish them,
trying to create a world in
which gentlemen were kept at
arm's length,
and their statements of
grievances and demands make very
interesting reading.
There's a rich literature on
these rebellions.
If anyone's interested in that
for an essay topic,
I'd be happy to advise you.
So in seeking to restore what
was essentially an idealized
vision of stable social
relationships,
the just commonwealth,
an ideal which they located in
a past golden age,
both the peasant rebels and the
literary Commonwealth Men,
the preachers and clergy,
had a great deal in common.
And together they give perhaps
the most vivid expression,
literary expression and
practical expression,
to the sense that many people
had in the mid-sixteenth century
that the bonds of society,
the bonds of commonwealth,
were fraying and falling apart.
But neither the Commonwealth's
Men in their books and sermons
nor the peasant rebels could
turn back the dynamic of change.
Moral exhortation or localized
protest by people who couldn't
face a royal army effectively
were not enough and both were
swept aside after 1549.
It's one of the nice ironies of
history that the place outside
Norwich,
now in the suburbs,
where Kett's rebels were
finally defeated very bloodily--
many were
slaughtered--Dussindale,
is now the site of a shopping
mall.
So the English peasantry made
their last stand there and it's
now a shopping mall,
a sort of shrine to modern
consumerism.
Amongst the murals that
decorate it there's one of
Robert Kett sitting under the
Tree of Reformation,
which I hope schoolchildren in
Norwich will all recognize as
they go about their shopping.
But it wasn't all repression.
There's another side to the
story.
By 1549, some people in
positions of authority in the
kingdom were equally concerned
about all of this and they were
trying to come to grips with
change in an alternative way.
A striking piece of evidence of
this is a wonderful composition
written for circulation in
manuscript in 1549 by Sir Thomas
Smith and entitled The
Discourse of the Commonweal of
England.
It's a remarkable piece of
writing.
It wasn't published until after
Smith's death,
and at one time it was actually
attributed to William
Shakespeare,
but it's now pretty certain
that it was written by Sir
Thomas Smith.
He was professor of civil law
at the University of Cambridge
and a leading member later in
his career of the royal Privy
Council under Edward VI and
subsequently under Elizabeth I.
Smith was trying to think out
the problems of his day,
not to denounce the moral
failings of particular
individuals or groups,
but to try to understand what
was going on,
to try to understand the
motives and the pressures that
were felt by different people in
society.
And he did that by having a
discussion.
He wrote a dialog between a
gentleman,
a husbandman--a peasant,
a craftsman--
a wage worker,
and a figure called the Doctor
who is a sort of academic figure
who acts as a kind of moderator
for this discussion.
He imagines them all sitting
outside a pub discussing the
affairs of the commonwealth.
It's because of this dialog
form that it was once attributed
to Shakespeare.
The representatives of the
different groups in The
Discourse of the Commonweal
put their own perspectives,
their own grievances.
The different voices of
different interest groups are
heard.
The Doctor who acts as
moderator provides a kind of
disinterested analytical
authority helping to explore the
underlying causes to propose
solutions,
to think of ways that the
interests of different groups
might be reconciled.
So, for example,
when the view is put by the
gentlemen that all men are free
"to make their most
advantage of that which is their
own," the phrase--
well, close to the
phrase--which was always being
denounced by the Commonwealth's
Men,
Smith has the Doctor reply not
by denouncing covetousness but
by saying,
yes, they may,
but they "may not abuse
their own...
to the damage of the
commonweal."
Good lords should set limits to
the pursuit of individual
economic interest.
In short then,
he's willing to accept the
simple reality of
self-interested behavior but he
seeks to prevent abuses or to
channel that behavior in ways
that it might serve the common
interest through the
encouragement of enterprise.
It's because of that kind of
attitude that Smith has been
described as the father of
political economy and there's
some justice in that.
But essentially,
putting him in his own time,
he was in the classical
humanist tradition.
He had great faith in the
positive effects of good
government as a means of
harmonizing conflicting
interests,
and that's what he's trying
essentially to achieve.
Well, Sir Thomas Smith wasn't
alone and he had considerable
influence upon like-minded
statesmen under Edward VI and
still more in the early years of
Elizabeth I.
He sat himself in Elizabeth's
council.
He was responsible for drafting
some of the early legislation of
her parliaments.
He was a very close friend of
her chief advisor,
Sir William Cecil.
And it led, this kind of
attitude among Smith and others,
to a kind of dual strategy on
the part of government which is
gradually emerging in the
mid-sixteenth century.
On the one hand,
they want to stabilize things;
they want to dampen things down;
they want to re-knit the
fraying fabric of the
commonwealth.
On the other hand,
they were very aware of the
need to pursue,
where possible,
orderly economic growth.
And this issued in a number of
statutes,
which are listed in the last
part of your handout and which
I'll just briefly mention,
which were intended to be steps
towards these ends.
In 1551, the coinage was
revalued and reissued in an
attempt to curb the worst
excesses of inflation.
In 1552, legislation was passed
against abuses in marketing
again with a view to the
problems occasioned by the price
rise.
In the 1550s,
the royal courts were made more
open to hear the grievances of
the peasantry,
some of whom had not previously
been able to plead in royal
courts.
In 1563--we're now into the
reign of Elizabeth--
the Statute of Artificers was
passed,
the longest single act of
Parliament passed in England
before the twentieth century,
which went into great detail in
attempts to regulate
relationships between employers
and employees;
to lay down rules,
to introduce for example annual
assessments of wages so that
wages could be adjusted in line
with prices.
In 1563, legislation was passed
to restrict not all forms of
enclosure but those forms of
enclosure which were thought to
be harmful.
If enclosure was beneficial it
would be permitted.
And in addition they
introduced, on the model of
experiments which had been
attempted in a number of towns,
forms of relief for the
impotent poor;
a constructive system of poor
relief which was to operate at
the level of the parish
involving the raising of money
from local taxation of those who
could afford it,
the "poor rate,"
and the dispersal of that money
to the impotent poor.
Finally, efforts were made to
encourage economically
enterprising people who brought
projects to the government:
the establishment of new trade
routes,
the encouragement of shipping
and fishing,
the establishment of new
manufacturing industries which
might be granted a royal patent,
giving them a monopoly until
they were established,--
it's the origins of the patent
system--
the encouragement of
immigration of skilled
Protestant refugees from abroad,
especially from the Netherlands
where the religious wars were
raging.
So one mustn't exaggerate the
impact of all of this.
This is the sixteenth century.
Their powers of enforcement
were limited.
But efforts were being made,
very visible efforts to do
something about the situation.
And that marked a significant
step forward in the conception
of the responsibilities of the
Tudor state,
a broadening of its role,
an increasing presence in
attempting to shape,
to channel, the economic and
social developments of the time,
to develop policy to deal with
the problems that they produced.
And that helped shape the
environment of change as people
gradually moved from the first
shocks of response to these
changing features of the
economic and social environment
and began to enter a period of
transition in the late sixteenth
century towards a more
thoroughly commercial economy,
which is something I'll touch
on later.
But for now we need to turn
back again,
having looked at what was
happening in the mid-sixteenth
century outside the religious
sphere,
to the issues of the
reformation and the settlement
which was attempted with the
accession in 1558 of Elizabeth,
and we'll take that up on
Tuesday.